-Now, I've got to share
some of my favorite
airport fail stories
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one
is from @Bamabeano.
-Ooh.
-He says, "I was running late
for a connecting flight
that was leaving
in five minutes.
So, I had to race from
gate A to gate G.
Halfway there I realized someone
was yelling out to me,
'Run, Forest, run!'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bamabeano.
-This one is from
@colleenm.
She says, "I was fiddling with
the side of my plane seat
and grabbed something I thought
was the recliner handle.
Then I realized I had decided to
stretch out behind me.
I had grabbed a bare foot."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-This one is from @Deanna MAD.
She says, "I took an edible
while waiting at the airport.
Ended up missing
my flight on purpose
because I was too relaxed and
wanted to finish watching
'The Great British Bake Off.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Hawaii is not going anywhere.
-Oh, wait. A foot.
-This one is from @Le Marz.
She says, "my brother and I were
at a self-check-in machine
when a woman behind us
asked for help.
After that, everyone thought
we were airport employees.
We were there for three hours
checking people into Toronto.
[ Applause ]
This one is from @wford22.
He says, "I was walking in
the airport to my gate
when a little kid ran
past me yelling,
'The poop is coming out!'"
[ Laughter ]
-Aw!
-Run, Forest, run!
[ Laughter ]
-Gate number two.
-This one is from @BohemianJenn.
She says, "A legit clown once
sat next to me on a plane.
When we made eye contact, he
felt the need to assure me
that he was a good clown,
not a creepy clown."
[ Applause ]
Or is that what a creepy clown
would say
to trick you in to thinking.
This one's from @Danielita89.
She says, "I fell asleep during
a long layover and woke up to
a little girl poking me
and asking out aloud,
'Mommy, is she alive?'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Leave the dead lady alone,
sweetheart.
Last one is from
@KatyByrneDesign.
She said, "I once sat next to a
man who slammed two servings
of nachos right after takeoff.
Later, when the flight hit
turbulence he started yelling,
'This isn't going to end well!'"
There you have it.
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.